[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu einer spezialausgabe von
führte nach 85 köpfe fünf meinungen an
einem tag an dem ein kinderkrankenhaus
in der ukraine bombardiert wurde an
einem tag an dem ex-kanzler gerhard
schröder offenbar auf eigene faust nach
moskau gereist ist um als angestellter
von vladimir putin seinem chef
persönlich zu sprechen und an einem tag
an dem der russische außenminister
lawrow auf eine lügen show abzieht und
sogar behauptet man habe die ukraine
nicht überfallen und es ist ein tag an
dem man sich vielleicht mehr gefragt
welche rolle bewohnern unser aller leben
noch spielt oder besser spielen sollte
all das jetzt hier bei viertel nach acht
mit fdp urgestein im bundestags-
vizepräsident wolfgang kubicki ich
begrüße auch der gewinn ist jan
fleischhauer sowie ebits militär und
russland experte juden röcke und
zugeschaltet ist bild vize paul
ronzheimer der diesem tag in kiew erlebt
hat und wir starten direkt mit jan
fleischhauer und seinen gedanken zu
gerhard schröder als putin freund der
auf friedensengel macht
nachricht des tages
jetzt schröder reist nach moskau um uns
allen den frieden zu bringen
meine mutter hätte gesagt schaden kann's
ja nicht ob es jetzt von erfolg gekrönt
ist ich zweifel dran ich glaube nicht
dass wladimir putin jemand ist der sich
an anderen menschen so emotional bindet
das wenn sie im tief in die augen gucken
und sagen lasst das wort handwerk dann
sagt nicht überlegt mir jetzt anders
möglicherweise ist es für gerd schröder
auch die exit option alle haben ja
gerätselt und haben auch wieder sehr
eingewirkt er solle jetzt endlich seine
aufsichtsrats mandate niederlegen und
haben ihm gerätselt warum er lässt sich
ganz fertig macht und möglicherweise
kommt er jetzt zurück und sagt ich habe
noch alles versucht ich habe jetzt auch
erkannt wladimir putin ist vom weg
abgekommen
ich muss mich jetzt zurückziehen wäre
jedenfalls einfacher dieser ausweg als
wenn auf saskia esken die
parteivorsitzende reagiert
also sprich er musste sich selbst auf
den weg machen seinen freund besuchen um
dann ein ausweg für sich selbst auch zu
haben weil sie vielleicht denkt er auch
wirklich er könne jetzt auch putin so
einwirken
dass der
friedenspläne mit ihm da schmiedet im
kreml
was immer er ja auch mitbringen wird
nach allem was die russen und die
russische regierung abgezogen haben in
den letzten wochen
das ist ja auch alles nichts wert ich
möchte heute haben wir keinen la france
gesehen in istanbul der sich einfach hin
setzt auf die frage eines glaube ich
türkischen journalisten
ob es denn weitere pläne gebe andere
länder zu überfallen nicht nur sagt nee
wir haben überhaupt keine pläne jemanden
zu überfallen wir haben ja noch nicht
mal die ukraine überfallen ich weiß gar
nicht wie man das krankheitsbild nennen
soll ja schwierige diagnose wir waren
auch paul ronzheimer live aus kiew
fragen und zugeschaltet paul wie kam
dieser besuch von gerd schröder jetzt in
moskau dort in der ukraine nach diesen
tag haben gerade darüber gesprochen was
heute an diesem tag alles passiert ist
das kinderkrankenhaus diese bilder kann
man überhaupt gar nicht aus dem kopf und
aus dem herzen bekommen und dann heute
diese überraschende nachricht gern
schröder macht sich auf
jan fleischhauer hat absolut recht es
ist schon ein bisschen die verrückteste
geschichte des tages ich konnte mir
darauf zunächst auch keinen reim machen
wenn man den bericht ein politiker liest
dann scheint es ja so gewesen zu sein
dass es einen ukrainischen abgeordneten
gab der kontakt aufgenommen hat
angeblich auf drängen des ukrainischen
präsidenten dafür gibt es bislang keine
bestätigung auch keine verifizierung der
sache aber wenn es so gewesen ist wie
bei politiker beschrieben dann wäre es
genau das was übrigens der botschafter
der ukraine andrej melik in der letzten
woche hierbei viertel nach acht ins
spiel gebracht hat also aus der
ukrainischen perspektive ist es so man
setzt einfach jede hoffnung auf jeden
strohhalm den es irgendwie geben könnte
und das ziel ist dass irgendwann sie
lenski wladimir putin gegenüber sitzt
denn das ist das was die ukraine wollen
das hat ja putin bislang immer abgelehnt
weil er sagt der sie lenski ist ja gar
nicht der präsident der ukraine weil wir
wissen wir mittlerweile putin er sagt
die ukraine gibt es gar nicht das ist ja
russland von daher wäre das ein schon
ein sieg für die ukraine wenn es dazu
käme ich glaube gerhard schröder macht
das kann sicher auch weil er
mittlerweile fast in einer sozialen
isolation ist wenn man mit alten
weggefährten von ihm spricht dann sagen
alle sie hätten sich abgewandt also es
ist wahrscheinlich in diesen tagen oder
diesen wochen für gerd schröder nicht
mehr leicht irgend jemanden zu finden
der mit ihm ins borchardt in berlin
gehen will und schnitzel ist würde das
hier am tisch jemand machen ich bin
journalist ich gebe die hefe im teig ist
wäre das super interessant ich meine
jetzt mal gerhard schröder gegenüber zu
sitzen und ihnen also man eindruck zu
gewinnen in welcher gemütsverfassung so
jemand ist man der war der kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland waren ja auch
nicht ganz unerfahren sind die herzen zu
geflogen ich glaube es gibt in der
politik der nachkriegszeit kein
vergleichbaren absturz also ich kann
mich an kein erinnern also so zum paria
zu werden ich meine sie haben jetzt wie
man lesen konnte in der parteizentrale
die gerhard schröder tassen mit seinem
konterfei entfernt und es gibt so eine
ehrengalerie im netz die 34 größten
sozialdemokraten letzte woche war es
dann nur noch 33 das wird ihn schmerzen
so dass
sie sagen haben kann es nicht das stimmt
sicher aber die frage ist doch wie
glaubwürdig glaubt er dann selber dass
er ist wenn er hinfährt also glaubt er
dass dahin fährt als gazprom mitarbeiter
oder als rosneft mitarbeiter oder als
jemand dessen unternehmen in zukunft co2
gerade zahlungsunfähig geworden ist oder
glaubt ihr wirklich dass er als
deutscher kanzler ehemaliger kanzler
dahin fährt oder als freund oder was
glauben sie wie dass ich so ein
angestellter zu seinem chef jacoby wie
bewerten sie diesen besuch ist ja
natürlich
schröder im borchardt wochen beim
schnitzel essen gehen und ich waidring
davor dass wir jetzt unsere
machtlosigkeit was ukraine konflikt
angeht dadurch kompensieren dass wir
jetzt zur hetzjagd blasen auf alle die
dies nicht schnell genug vor bleibt mir
putin distanzieren ich verstehe meine
menschenfreunde so dass jeder gesprächs
kann daher genutzt werden müssen ich
finde das auch dass es wichtig ist denn
wenn man mit putin nicht redet wird
dieser konflikt nicht zu ende gehen und
die frage was gehört wieder erreichen
werden wir sehen wenn der wie putin
geredet hat als ergebnis ich erwarte
davon auch nicht sehr viel
möglicherweise das bei gerhard schröder
auch zu der erkenntnis dass zu sein die
bisherige freundschaft zu putin so
belastet ist das nicht aufrechterhalten
werden kann aber noch einmal so zu tun
als müsse man mit putin nicht mehr leben
würde bedeuten wir warten darauf ist in
der ukraine besiegte oder russland ist
besiegt und der letzte das wird
definitiv nicht passieren insofern wenn
wir das töten beenden oder in der
ukraine muss jeder ein gesprächskanal
die offen gehalten werden kann genutzt
werden auch wenn es möglicherweise
aussichtslos ist das entscheidet er
gucke ich bis heute noch an die macht
der gesprächstherapie glaubt also ich
glaube nicht dran
sie wollen auch nicht mit waffengewalt
in russland marschieren putin zu
beseitigen also in die wollen einen
krieg auch beenden wollen sie gehen dort
laufen lassen
im gegensatz zu ihnen glaube ich nicht
dass wir
durch reden oder quatschen was ändern
sondern wenn überhaupt was was ändert
ist es zum einen jetzt der
widerstandskraft auch für putin
überraschende widerstandskraft des
ukrainischen volkes design vormarsch
entscheidend ins stocken gebracht haben
also bin ich ja jetzt auch über die
logistikprobleme und anderes mehr
und das zweite sind dann schon auch die
sanktionen die dazu führen dass also ich
gut was in russland ist jetzt in dieser
woche sehr anders aussieht als in der
woche davor
letzter konsequenz
gut was die sanktion angeht in loser ich
glaube nicht daran dass die jetzt dass
das russische volk gegen seinen
präsidenten auf steht also nach allem
was wir sehen können auch das natürlich
schwierig zu beurteilen
stehen die russen er hinter ihrem
präsidenten
aber ich meine die frage hätten wir uns
glaube ich
19 39 jetzt auch nicht anders gestellt
also im ausland hat man irgendwann auch
die
beziehungen die man hatte zum deutschen
reich gehabt dass das vernünftige was
man tun kann das interessante an putin
ist ja das erste offenbar das gespräch
sucht also ich er hat bei mir angerufen
oder anrufen lassen ob man mal reden
könne
das ist eigentlich eigenartig was
erwartet putin das micron sagt nach
alter schwerer lkw nämlich wieder die
weltgemeinschaft auf schwamm drüber so
ganz es ist also ich kann es nicht den
richtigen reim drauf machen also er will
die ganze zeit ja mit leuten aus dem
westen reden also alles geredet geredet
hat den israeli über sich empfangen so
also er hat putin hat großen redebedarf
das stimmt aber es ändert überhaupt
nichts also einer kriegsstrategie
wir sehen nicht hinter das heißt aber
auch gerade ich versuche das jetzt
einfach ich bin damit unsere kamera
männer von eine kleine herausforderung
aber wir wollen so aktuell wie möglich
sein ein bild male geschickt jetzt auch
gerade vielleicht wieder einmal ganz
umsonst ich verspreche ihnen wir reichen
es nach aber man kann es erkennen es ist
die frau von gerd schröder das hat so
jetzt blieben gerade gepostet
ganze ja sie hat gerade eben dieses
instagram foto gepostet wenn ich richtig
sehe ich muss es mir noch mal anschauen
sieht es so aus als würde sie beten oder
ich hab ja es sieht so aus als würde sie
beten und im hintergrund ist glaube ich
der kreml zu sehen wenn ich nicht mehr
das heißt gerhard schröder hat sie
mitgenommen auf seine reise dorthin nach
moskau und offenbar wollen sie sich dort
ganz bewusst auch inszenieren als
diejenigen die jetzt versuchen in diesen
stunden dafür zu sorgen dass es eine
basis für welche geartete
friedensverhandlungen gibt man muss
schon noch mal auf die wirkliche
skurrilität hinweisen denn gerhard
schröder hat es vorher nicht mit olaf
scholz besprochen er hat ist ihm nicht
mit spd chef lars klingbeil gesprochen
er hat es nicht mit aussenministerin
annalena baerbock besprochen und das ist
schon etwas wo man sagen muss dass es
durchaus erstaunlich als altkanzler
der ja auch sicherheit hat ich fragen ob
er sozusagen dort mit deutschen bka
beamten nach moskau gereist ist wie es
sein kann wenn das so ist dass er mit
deutschen beamten nach moskau gereist
ist warum die bundesregierung nicht weiß
dass gerhard schröder dort ist oder
nicht wusste bis zu dem zeitpunkt als
mein kollege peter tiede berichtet hat
und dann auch politiker berichtet hat
politiker dann mit der mit den
hintergründen dazu dass er tatsächlich
putin getroffen hat also da sind schon
viele fragen die sich stellen herr
kubicki sie haben zugehört haben aber
auch gerade eben im gespräch davor
gewarnt dafür ist keine hetzjagd aber
auch davon gesprochen das ist könnte ein
strohhalm sein jetzt hatten sie bei uns
haben zu der sagt das ist aber auch eine
situation die in einer gewissen
skurrilität nicht entbehrt wie finden
sie das in der tat dass dies in diesem
satz würdig zeit wirkt wirklich skurril
und wir werden sehen was dabei rauskommt
wenn es gelingt was wir alle hoffen
können das ist auch die art und weise
ein vernünftiges gespräch waren
aufgebaut wird dann ist doch in ordnung
auch wenn es nicht gelingt dann muss ich
hier spricht mit der gesamten heben mit
der deutschen öffentlichkeit
das ist ja mittlerweile auch schon
gewöhnt aber ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen um das mal zu sagen das geht
hat studio nach moskau reist und die
industrie weiß davon nichts es kann sein
dass das nicht abgesprochen ist das ist
das ist definitiv so dass die regierung
sagt dass das nicht mehr wussten
ja dass ist für touristenbusse
stattdessen ist für mich wirklich schwer
vorstellbar jedenfalls kann ich ihnen
dann sagen dann sind keine weg aber es
ist auch noch mitgereisten moskau was
haben wir denn das ist undenkbar weil
die bkm logischerweise mitteilen müssen
wenn sich in ein gebiet wie russland
gegeben dass sich dorthin begeben also
sofern haben wir das auch sehen die
nächsten tage werden wir es auf jeden
fall aufklären ich kann gehören das mag
jetzt ein bisschen merkwürdig klingen
ich kann nur hoffen dass die der besuch
von erfolg gekrönt ist und dass wir dann
zu einem spannung in der gruppe
beitragen kann und darf kommen dass das
töten und worden in der ukraine auf wird
und die russen sich was gott uns schenkt
mögen nach ostern zurückgegeben also
wenn es ihm gelingt kriegt er den
friedensnobelpreis das ist das wäre ein
bisschen übertrieben aber vielleicht
schon also von
heute zum engel ist ein ganz weiter weg
jedenfalls jedenfalls hat aber auch
schon andere teams reisen an die
kommunen anstehen an erinnerung
wiedergefunden
also vom schnitzel was mich interessiert
nur bei der preisvergabe skoda yavuz
aber es liefert so ist so ist ja
-kolumnist kann man einfach so frei
formuliert er wird vielleicht vom papst
empfangen aber nur weil wir ein bisschen
ruppiger
herr kubicki wenn ich ihnen noch eine
frage stellen darf moskau war das letzte
mal als wir uns gesehen haben saßen wir
gemeinsam in einer runde bei viertel
nach acht und haben auch über gerd
schröder diskutiert ich habe dort
sanktionen für gerhard schröder
gefordert bereits vor dem krieg ich
meine frage ist hatten sie in den
vergangenen wochen
kontakt mit gerhard schröder bzw
verstehen sie warum er bislang seine
posten nicht niedergelegt hat bei fragen
der zwei fragen gewesen kann ich beide
mit nein beantworten weder verstehe ich
noch immer dann den posten nicht
abgegeben hatte ist das wäre für mich
eine selbstverständlichkeit gewesen
gerade wenn man eine freundschaft die
beziehung hat ist das ein zeichen an die
andere seite das an die grenze
überschritten worden ist und ich
bedauerlicherweise keinen kontakt zu ihr
ich hätte das gerne gehabt auch um zu
wissen was einen big runde sind sich so
zu verhalten wie er sich verhält ist
nicht ans telefon haben sie es versucht
haben haben sie ich habe das so ich habe
seine seine privat der ihn angerufen
kann reaktion ich habe ihm eine sms
geschrieben keine reaktion
offensichtlich
hat er möglicherweise glaubt ich reihe
mich eine kur gegen die verdammten
wollen ja aber ich wollte einfach nur
seine big runde kennenlernen denn noch
einmal ein mensch der fleischhauer der
so viel politisches gespür die gerhard
schröder dokumentiert gerade dass man
dieses gespür im privaten bereich
verlassen hat es gibt ja nicht im
spiegel der werden schöne geschichte von
den kollegen hoya der reifen leuten
gesprochen hat die noch kontakt hatten
auf einmal den letzten tagen und einer
sagt also der geht so
nicht er ist der geisterfahrer alle an
wenn sie die geisterfahrer ja
das denken die meisten geisterfahrer die
auch schon gegangen und ich sind das
hier ist afrika sind
aber wir sprechen jetzt überall affront
für alle waren heute schockiert diese
worte zu hören wir haben die ukraine
überhaupt gar nicht überfallen wir
klingen diese worte an in der ukraine in
kiew an einem tag an dem ein
kinderkrankenhaus niedergebrannt wurde
an dem wir schwangere frauen gesehen
haben die verletzt nach draußen getragen
worden und dann diese zynischen diese
bösen worte wie hat man das aufgenommen
ja ich komme gerade wieder von einem
gespräch mit dem bürgermeister der stadt
kiew mit vitali klitschko das immer an
verschiedenen geheimen orten hier
stattfinden muss in der stadt weil auch
er auf einer todesliste steht und wir
haben lange danach noch nach dem
interview über labor auf gesprochen und
er hat gesagt
wie ein mensch wie ein mann damit leben
kann
solche lügen zu verbreiten wenn kinder
sterben menschen sterben wenn ein
kinderkrankenhaus kaputt gebombt ist das
ginge nicht in seinen kopf und er hat
sich lange damit befasst heute genau so
wie ich auch und die frage gestellt wie
kann jemand mit so einer schuld leben am
ende auch ein außenminister der
wahrscheinlich momentan der zynische die
brutalste außenminister ist denn es gibt
auf der welt de la force ist ja jemand
der tatsächlich perfektes englisch
spricht er wurde immer groß gepriesen
auch von den von vielen westlichen
diplomaten zumindest bis dahin als er
als die krim noch nicht überfallen wurde
also bis 2014 und viele diplomaten haben
von den tollen zigarren partys berichtet
die man mit sergej lawrow auf und dem
whisky dem man trinken könne und ich
frage mich und will das auch mal hier
zur diskussion stellen wie wird man so
hängt das allein an der abhängigkeit
anfuhr hat er angst dass wird er die
propaganda nicht mitmacht dass er dann
selbst ermordet wird oder was passiert
mit menschen die solche zynischen lügen
verbreiten also baut für mich ist sein
buch auch ministerium muss ich sagen auf
der einen seite wirklich ein erfahrener
diplomat jemand der der bei gesprächen
dabei war wahrscheinlich wo wir nur von
träumen können und mit leuten kontakt
hatten davon träumen können auf der
anderen seite jemand der und zwar nicht
erst seit jetzt sondern seit jahren
lügen erzählt die man sich einfach nicht
vorstellen kann also heute haben wir das
gehört mit es gibt keinen krieg mehr
dazu später aber seit jahren sagt er
beispielsweise
immer wenn es in syrien giftgas anschlag
gegeben habe dass das waren die rebellen
am um giftgas gekommen und haben sich
dann selber vergiftet und und wir wir
sind dann bloß die vorsichtigen die da
versuchen zu helfen mit dem hermann
assad insofern sergej wurf für mich
überhaupt nicht verständlich auf der
einen seite ein intelligenter mensch ein
mensch der wirklich weißwasser sagt
denkt man so auf der anderen seite
jemand der der völlig im ideologischen
der ideologischen babbel von herrn putin
zu leben scheint und wo man wenn man
ihnen sprechen hört nicht einfach nicht
weiß glaubte er was er sagt das ist wie
so ein tiefes psychoanalyse thema
kubicki wie sehen sie das glauben sie
wer handelt dann im auftrag gehandelt
weil er weiß dass will putin so also
bleibe ich auch dabei und verbreitet
dass weiter oder glaubt er dass am ende
selbst
also ich bin auch gab es zwischen
analytiker werde aber nicht dass ich
glaube nicht dass er das selbst glaubt
ich kenne da brauche ich hab' ich muss
gott persönlich schon getroffen war er
sieht bei dem was er sagt nicht wirklich
glücklich und ich wirklich überzeugend
aus momentan bewegt dass ich immer noch
auf der linie die akustische propaganda
das ist hier ja nicht um einen krieg
angeber fall handelt sondern um eine
befreiungsaktion nach wie vor gibt es ja
aus dem kreml dieses märchen von den
nazis die ukraine regieren die das
eigene volk unterdrücken und das volk
uns befreit werden und mit jedem
weiteren tag des krieges wird diese
paradiese
offenkundig entlarvt
und ich bin wirklich gespannt wie lange
auf die kurve kriegen will wenn das
alles nicht mehr zu neu kann ist weil es
auch sportlich geboren ist was gerade
passiert da könnte ja aus dem ansteigen
der ist ja der ethische außenminister
der welt ist die 18 jahre lang als
außenminister das gab ihnen muss man
auch schon gerüchte über den nachfolger
könnte müsste sich das nicht mehr antun
ich vermute arbeit ist immer noch
versucht dem kreml so wie ich ihn
einschätze er hört dann nicht zu den
fall solltest du den tauben schlimmeres
zu verhindern dennoch ich habe das auf
eine ausnahme fragen schon gemerkt oder
versucht zu erklären wenn man tut ihnen
irgendwie ecke drängt dann wird es
problematisch
einer ihrer kollegen von der welt hat
mal eine geschichte erzählt die putin
mal wieder erzählt von ader hatte die
sie als kinder empfangen wollen die
hacker braucht ja zum angriff
übergegangen ist das sondern mehrfach
erzählt und deshalb sage ich noch einmal
nicht wir hatten tun uns selbst keinen
gefallen bin mir zuerst dazu beitragen
sie schon schlimm genug aber
nicht wir müssen dokumentieren die
grenze die russland überschritten hat
ist eine grenze die dauerhaft oder
jeweils über längere zeit unser
verhältnis elementar beschädigt hat
weiter beschädigt und wir können nur
hoffen dass er zu einem vernünftigen
gesprächen und seine künftigen lösung
computer und verpflegte noch einmal
jeden tag zu sehen die menschen sterben
die kinder stellen das in ihrer
berichterstattung zu sehen das macht
einem auch würde das macht mich bürger
als beispielsweise die ganze chor und
ein fleischhauer das ging auch an sie
gibt es unterschiedliche
herangehensweisen an eine vielleicht
lösung
alle für alle menschen die im
religiösen raum bewandert sind ich
glaube wir sehen hier das böse ja das
ist so dass wir über putin da sehen wir
im gesicht von la france auch also wer
sich da hinstellt und sich letztlich
lustig macht über über tote kinder und
eben das ist ja ein satz der an
absurdität nicht zu überbieten ist wir
haben die kuh kranich überfallen filter
kein krieg
so die andere frage ja ich glaube dass
ich natürlich der westen gedanken machen
müssen das tut er auch stopp dass die
amerikanische administration darüber
sehr genau nachdenkt
welche möglichkeiten man
anbieten kann
[Musik]
aus dieser ecke in dir sicher manövriert
hat wieder rauszukommen so war weil
darüber steht ja noch viele zeitungen es
gibt ja auch immer eskalationsstufen
also im konventionellen krieg würde er
möglicherweise sogar verlieren gibt ja
zunehmend auch ernstzunehmende generelle
der bundeswehr oder der nato sagen also
wenn das jetzt so weitergeht und
jetzt noch also die regensaison sind der
macht stadt zukommt dann bleiben die im
wahrsten sinne des wortes immer stecken
so und das ist natürlich immer was ganz
anderes der mit atomwaffen vorstellen
kann und andere dinge der auch schon
angedroht so also darüber nachzudenken
wie man ihm etwas gibt kann ich da aber
das war es der toleranz immer noch viel
genauer darüber denken die
wahrscheinlich in der ukraine auch genau
nach
dass er vor sein volk treten kann und
sagen also ich hab ja auch etwas für
euch raus geholt es geht immer wieder um
diesen er darf er muss irgendwie ohne
gesichtsverlust da rauskommen paul ohne
gesichtsverlust gibt es das überhaupt
noch wenn wir jetzt auch diese
zynische worte von lavrov sehen da muss
doch irgendwann der punkt kommen wo der
gesamten welt auch russland klage zu das
kann man nicht aufrechterhalten wie
villa da was kann man anbieten
ja ich glaube es gibt viele dramatische
aber auch interessante entwicklungen
neben dem drama und dem tod der hier
passiert in der ukraine sehen wir in
russland das heute das hat mein kollege
philipp jakob analysiert das erste mal
das staatsfernsehen den krieg den sie
nennen die noch nicht krieg aber die
sogenannte operation
dort kritisiert und fragen aufwirft und
tatsächlich ist es ja so dass man ganz
unabhängig davon dass natürlich russland
auf dauer der ukraine
militärisch überlegen ist darüber
brauchen wir nicht reden aber wenn man
sich die jetzigen zeitpunkt die dinge
anschaut ist es weiterhin so dass
russland keine einzige wirkliche
großstadt eingenommen hat also auch
aktiv da haben wir den einsatz von
streubomben gesehen ist nicht
eingenommen von russland mario pohl ist
eingekreist und es gibt grausame kriege
aber weiterhin nicht eingenommen von
russland und das sei eine weitere
wichtige stadt nicht eingenommen und in
kiel wo schon seitdem ich hier
angekommen bin also ein bisschen das
zeitgefühl verloren auch us dienste
immer wieder gesagt haben innerhalb von
stunden tagen waren auch immer könntet
ihr fallen kiew steht also militärisch
sieht es momentan
nicht besonders gut aus für ihn jetzt
kann er natürlich sagen also für
wladimir putin er will noch brutaler
werden das würde bedeuten dass die
sanktion
vielleicht noch schärfer werden wir dann
auch in deutschland einen öl- und
gas-embargo erleben dass der druck auch
innenpolitisch für ihn schwieriger wird
oder er versucht eine lösung zu finden
in einer verhandlung da gab es erste
zeichen in die richtung das erste mal
dieses auch das lenski doch irgendwie
präsident bleiben könne wenn er denn
akzeptiere dass die ukraine neutral wird
dass sie nicht der nato ist dass teile
des bombers weg sind und so weiter und
so fort nur das sorgt dann gleichzeitig
für eine große problematik hier ich war
gestern nach dem interview noch länger
im präsidenten gebäude bei bludenz gibt
und mit ihm weiter gesprochen beratern
gesprochen und natürlich wissen die das
momentan die situation in der ukraine so
ist das die mehrheit eine
hintersee lenz gestellt und die mehrheit
auch vereint ist in diesem patriotischen
blick auf das ganze und sagt nein wir
verteidigen uns wenn sie lenski jetzt
sagt in gesprächen ich bin zu allem
möglichen bereit und ich gebe mein land
her dann kann das bedeuten dass die
lenski nicht mehr lange präsident ist
und sozusagen hier eine innere die
stabilität
und das ist glaube ich das ganz ganz
schwierige im übrigen wenn wir über
kanäle sprechen zu deutschland und zum
regierungschef da tut man es war so dass
man telefoniert aber der austausch an
informationen
so wie ich das aus der ukraine erlebe da
ist man eigentlich ziemlich bedient was
deutschland angeht aber das nur am rande
also die enttäuschung ja ist groß auch
für das was deutschland übrig hat für
das was deutschland tut in diesem
konflikt vor dass schillers zu uns immer
wieder wir werden bei uns unsere
militärexperte unser russlandexperte wir
sprechen ausgangs mäßig überlauf über
diese äußerungen über diese unfassbaren
zynischen äußerungen spliff wenn ich nur
bei diesem satz der dort gefallen ist
sondern es war zeigte wieder einmal wie
giftig dieser propaganda apparat putins
ist wieweit erwirkt und du hast uns
heute auch in seinen beobachtungen wir
blicken auch besonders nach mario pohl
heute diese schrecklichen bilder weitere
beobachtungen mitgebracht die zeigen wie
dieses system überhaupt wirkt wie das
funktioniert ganz genau also wir haben
ja viele aussagen heute von der brauch
gehört dass mit dem krieg das kann man
vielleicht noch sagen okay das ist
nämlich der operation das sehen wir
anders aber er hat auch über diesen
angriff auf die geburtsklinik gestern in
mario pohl gesprochen und was er da
geliefert hat war dass er gesagt hat es
ist es gab diesen angriff überhaupt
nicht auf eine geburtsklinik es gab eine
angriff auf ein militärisches ziel und
es gab da auch keine frauen und kinder
dann fragt man sich was nicht dass wir
frauen kinder und das hat dann seine
seine seinen apparat seine
außenministerium und auch die
verschiedenen botschaft in den sozialen
medien weiter getrieben wir haben
behauptet und wir sehen uns hier das
sind schauspieler da wurden schauspieler
hingebracht von den ukrainern um dort
etwas um dort etwas darzustellen dass
dort ein angriff stattgefunden hat haben
also befunden dass eine von denen hat
gemordet und hat mit instagram account
und diese instagram account wurde als
beweis dafür genommen dass das alles
nicht stimmt und da setzt mein punkt an
was wir sehen also einmal dass die
russische führung propaganda macht gut
dass sie machen das ist ihr ding aber
wir sehen dass diese propaganda von
unfassbar vielen kanälen
verbreitet werden von der russischen
regierung und das verstehe ich nicht wie
kann das noch sein wie kann es sein dass
twitter beispielsweise in russland
blockiert ist aber eine russische
botschaft über twitter die welt
vergiften darf mit dieser propaganda
behaupten darf dass diese frau dort
beispielsweise eine schauspielerin ist
wie kann es sein dass facebook in
russland blockiert wird aber über
facebook alle möglichen troll und so
weiter accounts aus in petersburg und co
hier gift verbreiten dürfen und zu guter
letzt das gleiche gilt auch für die
russische medien ich verstehe weiterhin
nicht dass wir es akzeptieren dass
deutsche meldet beispielsweise in
russland blockiert wird und er tdi
weiterhin senden darf in deutschland
sowohl auf der homepage als auch über
fernsehen und zehn jahres programm das
über viele kanäle zu erreichen ist
deshalb mein punkt hier diese propaganda
muss aufhören wir müssen dafür sorgen
unsere bundesregierung muss dafür sorgen
dass diese propaganda wenn sie
vorsichtiger richtungen verbreitet wird
nicht auch noch auf englisch französisch
spanisch deutsch und so weiter in alle
kanäle weiter geflutet kann wird und wir
sehen es war ein teil der öffentlichkeit
wirkt dass ein teil der öffentlichkeit
gesehen was auch immer wie immer in den
kommentaren zu unseren dingen die wir
veröffentlichen zu unseren
berichterstattung anteil der
öffentlichkeit glaubt es gibt keinen
russischen angriff auf die ukraine und
was wir hier sehen in dem video was
neben beläuft sind schauspieler die vom
ukrainischen nazis missbraucht wurden um
mir einen russischen angriff
vorzutäuschen solange so was bei uns
gesendet werden darf
verliere ich so ein bisschen meinen
glauben an den rechtsstaat auch in
deutschland und an die wehrhafte
demokratie
herr kubicki geht der bundesregierung
nicht scharf genug gegen diese art der
informationsverarbeitung vor jetzt
zunächst einmal nannte diesen größte
russische botschaft in london
nach fünf stunden vielen dank ja noch
einmal wann immer man dass das zutrifft
ist neben brauchen gewisse zeit um
herauszufinden ob das tatsächlich jetzt
sind oder auch nicht ich warne dringend
davor wir sind ein rechtsstaat der der
meinungsfreiheit im sommer weiß wirklich
ist artikel
für jedermann und ich war auch dringend
davor jetzt so zu tun als müssten wir
genauso reagieren die russen die
verbieten dass man krieg nicht mehr
krieg nennen darf und wir verbieten
jetzt das russische russische
informationen irgendwie eingespeist wird
abgesehen davon dass wir uns auch gar
nicht komplett um wir binden können es
sei denn wir würden uns von allen
informationskanälen im social media
bereich komplett abbilden was einfach
nicht funktioniert auch nicht geht was
wir tun können ist durch offensive
aufklärung darauf hinzuweisen dass die
tatsächlich in die propagandamaschine
dabei ist ein krieg der ein krieg ist
wieder zu beuteln oder aber in die
falsche richtung zu verherrlichen das
ist eine aufgabe der medien wie bild
bild am sonntag
welches jeden fall zu den medien geht
dort sehr zu dokumentieren gerade weil
man das auch teilweise überprüfen gerade
darstellen kann dass ein krieg
stattfindet der wirklich unmenschlich
ist der auch völkerrechtswidrig ist der
auch kriegsverbrechen beinhaltet und
dass man dokumentiert das ist nicht
geschehen und dass man unter umständen
dafür verantwortlich sind irgendwann mal
zur verantwortung ziehen kann so wie es
der internationale strafgerichtshof
dagegen weil ich schon gerade tut aber
jetzt zu sagen alles was uns jetzt
momentan nicht gefällt an informationen
nachrichten muss verboten werden halte
ich für falsch es muss entschärft werden
und zu dokumentieren
da sie ja als westliche welt in die
meinungsfreiheit hoch achten und davon
ausgehen dass informationen dann auch
valide sind für mich einfach zu programm
das wirken als lügen getan daher kann
also mein eindruck ist dass die russen
also den krieg schon längst verloren
haben also den krieg und bilder und um
stimmung
das reicht das schon zu sehen auf der
einen seite dieses krokodil wie la
france ja sowieso notruf noch
zusammengehalten wird oder dem gebot
texten putin das gesicht immer
breitflächige wird und man denkt unseren
platz der an diesen immer länger werden
den tischen ja ich glaube das letzte mal
hatte jetzt den rekord gebrochen ich
habe 32 oder seine
zentralbankchef in sitzen der war ja
noch länger halten so und dagegen
zielinski
im gespräch mit ronzheimer oder
oder in diesen in diesen videos
übernächtigt ein junger mann der seinem
volk mut zuspricht ich weiß gar nicht
dass ich das letzte mal er putin
rausgekommen ist man weiß ja nicht mal
wo er sich aufhält wahrscheinlich in
irgendwelchen stadien willen oder
bunkern die schon stadien gebaut hat
weil er angst hatte vergiftet zu werden
also ich dieses diese videos die wir
gesehen haben mit diesen aeroflot
mitarbeiterin da ist ja mittlerweile
fraglich ob er überhaupt jemals gesessen
hat oder ob da nicht rein geschnitten
haben was man ihr mal sieht wie seine
hand durchs mikrofon ist die ehre platt
mitarbeiterin war auch er eine
sicherheitswache so also
insofern also ich glaube
die sieht man in russland nicht die
sehen alle aber direkt an russland aber
dieser wir reden jetzt gerade von rt
deutschland also zu sagen
deutschland wird europas wird der welt
so und da
das gibt auch hier verrückte die
wahrscheinlich ein putin die daumen
drücken ja aber das ist wirklich eine
kleine verschwindende minderheit also da
wird man dann einen anderen bei der afg
finden
und doch ganz links von der linkspartei
aber so also dass das ist diese nation
hat sich zum welt paria gemacht
selbst also nicht mal der chinese hat ja
in dem gespräch mit makro und unter
bundeskanzler irgendein versuch
unternommen
zu sagen da ja das ist dann nicht so
schlimm oder man muss die russen
verstehen also
an diesen fakten
besteht außerhalb von russland kein
zweifel so gut dass beim eigenen volk
sieht anders aus da hat er nun alles
abgeschnitten also ich finde er viel
sollten versuchen
den leuten in russland
unsere information zugänglich zu machen
wie auch immer
sind ja auch den ein oder anderen
vielleicht dort geben der gerne mein
feind im f1 sender sowie damals ja bei
der bbc 19 44 mal gehört wie die welt
sich wirklich eigentlich dreht
empfindest du erst in der ukraine diese
diskussion die wir hier gerade fühlen
auf der einen seite die forderung von
juli an ganz klar sagt solche
informationen dürfen hier in deutschland
nicht verbreitet werden aber auch herr
kubicki der sagt die aufgabe von
journalisten ist es diese zu entlarven
und nicht dass diese informationen
gestoppt werden dass ein feiner grat
ja das ist ein schmaler grat was ich
aber bei der diskussion interessant
finde dass bei twitter und facebook der
sturm aufs kapital gereicht hat um
donald trump überall rauszuschmeißen und
rauszuwerfen und zu blockieren twitter
ist er nicht mehr facebook ist nicht
mehr und viele kanäle auch der auch der
russische staatspräsident putin hat
einen zwar nicht personalisierten aber
einen staatspräsidenten kanal und zu
weit ich weiß hat darüber noch niemand
diskutiert also das sozusagen die
russischen amtsträger die gerade in
diesem moment
kinderkrankenhäuser bombardieren lassen
die dürfen da weiterhin in diesen
kanälen auftauchen deswegen ich bin
jetzt gar nicht entschlossen in der
einen oder anderen richtung durch finde
schon dass das wieder ein beispiel dafür
ist wie mit zweierlei maß gemessen wird
und das offenbar ja die aufregung in den
sozialen medien größer ist wenn es um
donald trump geht als wir das bereitet
mir putin geht
hier lernt ja so vielseitig also ich
finde es immer ich will ein bisschen
schwierig egal was herr kubicki gesagt
hat was hat denn das mit
meinungsfreiheit zu tun was hat denn das
also wie kann man dann sagen wir können
das doch nicht so machen wie die wollen
sie sagen dass deutsche welle ein teil
der deutschen hybriden kriegsführung
gegen russland ist das würde ich nicht
sagen ich würde aber sagen dass lte ein
teil der russischen übrigen
kriegsführung gegen deutschland und
gegen den westen ist und insofern
verstehe ich nicht dass man sagt wir
können doch nicht genauso wie die das
machen um meinungsfreiheit mit über
wussten natürlich wort meinungsfreiheit
groß geschrieben und deshalb genau
deshalb sollten wir aufpassen dass das
im rahmen der meinungsfreiheit auch
berichtet werden darf aber im rahmen des
staatlich gelenkten desinformation zur
schwächung und spaltung unserer
gesellschaft nicht gesendet werden darf
sehen sie da keinen unterschied
also ich sehe einen unterschied zwischen
der freien sondern der staatliche linken
presse aber ich habe große probleme
damit die gäste locker vom hocker sagen
wenn ihr den letztlich darüber
entscheiden soll was zensiert wird über
sich zensiert wird das
selbstverständlich können wir staatliche
russische sender an der ausstellung in
der europäischen union in deutschland
hindern das ist recht die gar kein
problem aber andererseits löst sich der
jetzt nicht wieso wir uns dann aufregung
darüber dass die russen dann ihrerseits
staatlich finanzierte sender aus
deutschland für an der sendung in
russland hindern würden ich meine das
ist immer so eine geschichte in der
frage der wechselseitigen und
gegenseitige abhängigkeit ich muss mich
jetzt nicht an zu entscheiden was jetzt
hin zu unterliegen sondern etwas nicht
abgesehen darf und dass ich mich
innerlich gegen jeden gedanken wäre wenn
da nur solange tragfähigere vollständig
erfüllt werden also wir kommen ganz
merkwürdige situation in der
wir so eine art
meinungsführerschaft beanspruchen und
nicht genau sagen können wir der letzt
entscheider ist das frage ist sind sie
hasst ist es die bild -zeitung ist es
einen rat ein expertenrat bei der
bundesregierung gehen und sagen soll
selbst verstand sich nicht aber wenn ich
was falsch machen wirklich innenhöfe
presserat wenn er hat dir was war ich
mache niemanden beruhigen
die wir hier jetzt gerade nicht auflösen
können denn wir machen eine ganz kurze
pause und wir fragen uns dann nach
dieser pause wie geht es eigentlich
weiter mit corona und es erscheint ein
bisschen seltsam in zeiten des krieges
darüber zu sprechen denn das gerät fast
schon in vergessenheit paul ronzheimer
bei uns zugeschaltet vielen herzlichen
dank an dich paul aus kiew und wir sind
nach einer kurzen pause hier wieder für
sie dabei und wirklich alles gute und
sagen wir lassen sie uns nicht ausruhen
von uns auch weil dankeschön
[Musik]
bild
das box highlight live bei bild
[Musik]
felix sturm auf dem weg zum
weltmeistertitel
der kampf gegen israel
so kommt zurück gelegt
die boxnacht am
26 märz bei bild dieser sendung wird
präsentiert von governor of poker 3 die
gratis poker app fürs handy
bild
[Musik]
willkommen zurück bei viertel nach acht
und wir sprechen jetzt über das thema
kuroda das irgendwie in den hintergrund
gerückt dass angesichts dieses
schrecklichen krieges spielt es
überhaupt noch eine rolle jetzt gerade
in ihrem leben da war doch was mit der
impfpflicht kommt die jetzt oder kommt
jetzt nicht herr kubicki
zunächst einmal haben sie recht hinter
diese kritischer ereignisse dreht sich
die korona dann nämlich wirklich zurück
auch im bewusstsein der bedeutung war
den menschen vielleicht wohl natürlich
die position geht es darauf verständigt
einen glaubenskrieg tierschutzgesetz
nächste woche zu verabschieden was noch
nächsten vater in kraft treten soll und
das wird nicht dazu führen dass wir im
zwanzigsten jahr
zweites team damit zurück geben es gibt
keinerlei beschränkungen werden kann
wenn dort ein leben bei betrieben wenn
die länder sind in der lage mit masken
pflichten anzuordnen wenn sie es für
notwendig erachten für alten und
pflegeheime testungen für altenpflege
eine krankenhäuser und auch schulen wenn
sie wie gesagt dass wir möglichkeiten
und es gibt die möglichkeit
dass die langen tage schließen können
weitergeben danach nahmen aber davon
auszugehen dass war sehr hungrigen
ergänzen aber keine züge mehr zu den
krankenhäusern beziehungsweise
wesentlichen fünf stationen dank der
tatsache dass wir am 20 märz weitgehend
sondern weil ich sie zurückkehren glaub
ich nicht mehr das nicht nur auch
getrunken kann denn österreich sagt sie
gerade ab und dass wir sie als einziges
demokratisches land einführen halte ich
für ausgeschlossen da rüber zum
deutschen bundestag keine mehrheit gegen
sofern beruhigte sich die situation
etwas wehren ab von der angst getrieben
mit blicken zu einer vernünftigen mit
mars land zu regieren es notwendig ist
aber nichts auf vorrat zu produzieren
was dazu führen kann dass die menschen
weiter ängstlich sind und jedes leben
ist
also die impfpflicht muss spätestens
jetzt vom tisch sein fleischhauer sehen
sie als außerdem überhaupt noch
irgendeine chance dass sie kommt sowieso
in vergessenheit geraten ich dachte es
für die ganze hat der plan der
bundesregierung hat als lägen aber noch
mal öfter treffen zu schieben
dass sie sich von selbst erledigt ich
meine hat ja im ersten schritt glaube
ich dass es eine gewissensentscheidung
der abgeordneten gemacht
unter sich wie kubicki also ich glaube
nicht dass ich dafür jetzt eine mehrheit
im bundestag findet sich ebenfalls für
eine sache die jedoch
bei den leuten nach wie vor hoch
umstritten ist aber dennoch man hält
daran fest also wieder reformen
das kriegen wir jetzt im bundestag ein
und dann fällt es irgendwie ins große
loch fällt einfach irgendwie haben wir
nie gesagt wäre doch aber dann hat man
hauptmann gezeigt man wollte das
richtige und ja
das thema ist wie gesagt also auch
crooner mit allem drum und dran also
herr lauterbach warnt ja tapfer
jede woche von neuen wellen ich glaube
jetzt vor der sechsten oder wir sind in
der sechsten und diese hat vor der
siebten und dann kommt man der
sommerrallye oder kubicki waren mal
wieder ja
also und ich hab jetzt starb vor in der
letzten woche sich doch hier gibt es
unseren terminkalender für journalisten
wichtige termine also man sich oben
stand robert wieder karl lauterbach der
gesundheitsminister informieren über die
grünanlage
der termin abgesagt wegen mangelndem
interesse so dass da stehen wir heute
und muss man sagen gott lob aber dennoch
einer kubicki ihre partei sieht dies
genauso wie sie also glauben sie auch
dass vonseiten fdp dabei komme sagt da
war doch mal was mit der impfpflicht
sollten wir nicht wollten wir nicht
ich kann nur sagen dass eine deutliche
mehrheit in meiner fraktion dass du
sieht wie ich es gibt auch kollegen und
kollegen die für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht rotieren ganz wenige und es
gibt kollegen und kollegen unter führung
von ullmann die für alle impfpflicht auf
50 notieren aus meiner sicht macht es
keinen sinn mehr denn je und gepolsterte
ganz genau seziert und in texas ein
gehilfe wir haben riesen instanzen und
es kommt auch keine ungenutzten mehr
weil in den stationen und ein insofern
macht die impfpflicht keinen sinn und
dass wir uns vor einer welle sagt der
dauerwelle frau kallwass dauerwelle
schützen müssen mit einem stock wir noch
gar nicht kennen halte ich für rechtlich
kaum vertreter verein ich würde nicht
mehr kommunizieren wollen ihn bei ihr ab
20 mehr als alle beschränkenden regeln
im normalen täglichen leben nicht mehr
haben werden es gibt keine massen
kirchberg an der abstandsregler nicht
alle 23
wir können das mit allen möglichen
menschen wieder treffen bei
veranstaltungen lieder größen sache wenn
wir das so machen und das wird nächsten
donnerstag beschlossen werden dann macht
die anfälligkeiten sind auf vorrat vor
einigen wir mittlerweile auch wissen ich
bin doch deutlich ältere generation muss
man sagen dass der schutz der durch die
impfung erfolgt auch für mich selbst nur
von begrenzter dabei ist und es gar kein
trend schutz mehr gibt bei einer impfung
für dritte personen bei bier wie gesagt
selbst als geben sie den flexibus träger
sein würden dennoch haben wir ja die
ganze zeit ist auch über monate gehört
die im kaufen sie muss weiter nach oben
gehen vor allem die ddr zeitpunkt noch
nicht abgeholt haben die zweitimpfung
noch nicht abholte doch kann ich an den
booster denken das sind die zahlen die
es endlich nach oben gehen dass wir
dieses ganze ding ist unter den tisch
fallen und dann surfen wir in den winter
ein von dem jeder wand und sagen ja na
ja gut ist haben wir das irgendwie am
anfang des jahres nicht so richtig auf
die kette bekommen machen wir jetzt halt
noch so skurril das klingen mag aber die
am besten geschützten sind die imker
sich infiziert werden die sind jetzt
tatsächlich der natürliche immunität
versehen die längere zeit auch anhält
und die auch verschiedene varianten
identifizieren können also das ist
wirklich ein treppenwitz der geschichte
dass ausgerechnet die ist geweigert
haben aber infizierte nun am besten
geschützt sind ich glaube dass mal
anders gesehen oder das hat das lka
anders erklärt ja interessanterweise
sind die von diesem thema unter das war
bei der data variante noch etwas anderes
als bei der variante aber wenn sie
virologen gehören fragen sie hindurch
stieg beispielsweise ja sagt das auch
regelmäßig auch christian preussner dass
ein podcast beim ndr habe gesagt
dann ist es eine frage der eigenen
risikoeinschätzung wenn man sich impfen
lassen will oder nicht ich plädiere dass
ich habe ein richtig gutes gefühl gehabt
nach der info bei ich mir gedacht habe
jetzt musst du keine angst mehr vor der
infektion haben aber das sollen die
leute im zweifel selbst entscheiden sie
zusätzlich hinhaltenden widerstand von
vielen gesellschaftlichen gruppen halte
ich für nicht durchsetzbar in dieser
republik aber wie soll das dann
durchsetzbar sein sie sagt jetzt auch
beide ja das wird man so ein bisschen
unter den tisch fallen lassen das wird
sich aus denn noch haben wir ja auch
immer wieder im bundeskanzler jetzt auch
noch mal gesagt er hält daran fest es
wie kann man das durchziehen ohne dass
man dann öffentlich benennen es macht
jetzt keinen sinn wenn wir schauen uns
an also ist sehr schön die leute sagen
es macht keinen sinn wir aber wie kommt
man aus der nummer raus als bundeswehr
durch abstimmung im deutschen bundestag
wir werden in der ersten aprilwoche
darüber abstimmen und dann werden wir
feststellen wo die mehrheiten und wie
ihm mehrheiten sind ich sage ja gesagt
ich kann mir momentan nicht vorstellen
dass es an dem er dem deutschen
bundestag gibt ich kann das aber auch
nicht ausschließen aber
für sehr wahrscheinlich dann werden
ihnen dann wird dieses gesetzentwurf zur
einführung der helmpflicht schlicht und
ergreifend nicht beschlossen und dann
gibt es gar nicht also war ja lange
finanzminister unsere angela merkel und
hat er sich das ein oder andere
abgeguckt und wenn wir uns erinnern
angela merkel war immer ganz großem
waren ja und dann sagst in diesem
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat gerät
also so schlimm mit den zahlen wir
müssen unbedingt was machen und dann hat
sie das auch in pressekonferenzen
vertreten hat gehört ich konnte mich
leider nicht durchsetzen das hat ihr nie
jemand als führungsschwäche ausgelegt
sondern immer wenn es dann nachher
wieder hoch ging die frau merkel hat
rechtzeitig gewarnt und dieser effekt
wird auch bei olaf scholz einsetzen das
heißt er war für die dokumentiert für
die impfpflicht und wenn dann die zahlen
jetzt im winter wieder steigen wird er
sagen freunde ich hab's euch gesagt
das ist also dann die takte geben die
man vorgibt also ich konnte mich leider
nicht durch der kubicki glauben sie dass
die strategie sein wird glauben wir dass
wir genau das erleben werden was herr
fleischer oder zeichnet ich vermute dass
sie ähnlich wie bei putin gar keine
wirkliche strategie dahinter steckt
momentan was die impfpflicht angeht ja
denn bis zur bundestagswahl und drei
wochen noch danach war ja oder spritzig
wie alle anderen auch gegen eine
allgemeine impfpflicht und an den das
erkenntnis die sich ja nicht gewartet
hat ihren sohn zu haben und ihnen
erklären lassen herr wolle jetzt die
allgemeine impfpflicht
ich glaube das wird genauso passieren
die mit angela merkel fleisch aber bei
der frage für alle ist ja gesagt sie sei
dagegen hat die abstimmung freigegeben
hat dann gegen die g für alle gestimmt
und trotzdem ist sie gekommen hier war
es umgekehrt sein hier werden wir
feststellen dass oder schuld feststellt
die abgeordneten haben sich so
entschieden das ist parlamentarismus das
ist unsere verfassung die das vorgibt
und diese boote beuge ich mich jetzt ich
habe andere über zwei andere kenntnisse
aber gleichwohl in einer demokratie mehr
im parlament wissen sie was das soll dem
coupé geht das toller ist bei dieser
entscheidung auf die situation sprechen
kommt mit der ehe für alle wenn sie
heute leute fragen dann 90 prozent
würden schwören die angela war natürlich
für die ehe wie wir alle es
kann von frau merkel die länder hätten
wir sagen ja also erst mal widersprechen
kann ich herrn kubicki nicht weil ich
sehe es mit der ich ganz genauso mit der
aktuellen variante des virus glaube ich
gibt es da überhaupt gar keine
notwendigkeit ich will aber noch mal auf
diese auf diese wahrnehmung zurückkommen
also ich hab grad normal hinguckt
262.000 neuinfektionen hatten wir
gestern
hätten wir das vor einer vor zwei wochen
gehabt oder vor zwei monaten oder oder
vor zwei jahren wäre explodiert alle wir
hätten ja wir hatten ja was und ich
möchte auch gar nichts an die data
varianten sondern war wesentlich auch
glaube ich habe auch vor einem monat
hätten wir doch wer hat noch nur darüber
berichtet und war auch wir jetzt mal
wieder als bild ja wir hatten gesagt
unglaublich die höchste instanz jemals
und so viele und insofern finde ich
schon wirklich spannend wie dieses thema
aus der wahrnehmung so so schnell
verschwunden ist hat die haben es gehört
nicht mal mehr über den
pressekonferenzen des
gesundheitsministers kriegt man genug
interesse dafür
ich glaube da sollten wir auch als
medien dann in dem fall und zwar wissen
selbst an die nase greifen also ja die
politik hat einen sehr sehr große
mitverantwortung wie das die thema
gehandhabt wird aber ich glaube die
medien und die öffentlichkeit die wir
brauchten auch immer irgendwas wir
wollten uns auch irgendwas meisten leute
haben cia ließ dann haben sie auch
gelesen die artikel ja wenn ich eine
viertelmillion corona fälle gestern da
dreht auch meine oma erst mal durch ja
aber wenn wir jetzt sehen das thema
wurde so unfassbar schnell irgendwie aus
der ersten reihe verbannt und wurde
durch ein anderes abgedeckt wird er
hatte schon zwei jahre beschäftigt das
stimmt das schöne aber sagen wir so wir
haben jetzt eine weltpolitische krise
die uns auch wieder an der tankstelle
und so weiter betrifft also insofern
sehen wir ja das ist ja nicht bloß
irgendwo in der ukraine ist sondern wir
sehen da die auswirkung glaub ich bei
jedem ihrer gasrechnung zum beispiel
insofern sehen wir das jetzt eine andere
krise da ist und man kann nur hoffen
dass auch von den varianten her omikron
und
möglichst lange erhalten bleibt wenn man
so möchte und wir nicht irgendwie jetzt
dieses datacon oder was auch immer
bekommen wofür lauterbach warnt und das
ebenso bleibt dass wir vorinstanzen
haben aber geringe krankenhaus sagen
geringe todeszahlen haben und uns
endlich wieder auf die wichtigen dinge
des lebens konzentrieren aber das
lustige ist einige experten schule jetzt
schon um
also ich habe die leopoldina zb erinnern
uns noch im letzten winter her also das
jetzt an sofortmaßnahmen sein muss ja
weil sonst wenn die sofortmaßnahmen
durchkommen alles ganz schrecklich
diese woche erneut stellungnahme der
leopoldina diesmal
wenn sich deutschland vom gas und öl
abkoppelt überhaupt kein problem ja wir
haben das durchgerechnet also wieder so
modelliert ja da gibt es den kleinen
unwucht im wirtschaftssystem aber im
prinzip
dass hindrichs toll also die leopoldina
fragen zu allen christen studien
zu ergänzen wir das noch ihr am herzen
liegt das ist ein unterschied auf der
welt aber unterlegen oder nicht reden
denn wir hatten tatsächlich eine
situation wo selbst ich die befürchtung
hatte unser gesundheitssystem könnte
durch die bälle tatsächlich überlastet
werden das haben wir momentan nicht wir
haben diesen lizenzen und trotzdem kann
die zugänge zu den krankenhäusern was
darauf hindeutet dass auch bei den
umgebenden die omikron infizierung
leichter verläuft als ist der
vergangenheit der frage wie es ist wir
können von glück sagen dass wir uns in
dieser situation befinden und lassen
sich auch sagen wenn sich jetzt alle
infizieren würden wie alle
eingeschlossen werden dadurch auch ein
natürlich mitbekommen würden dann so
christian drosten werden wir mit dem
thema durch auch was im winter der
herbst anbieter angeht und ich hoffe und
vermutet dass auch das ist gar nicht
schwer bei hand gegeben wird denn wie
gesagt die hohen infektionszahlen deuten
daraufhin dass virus verbreitet sich als
verwandte massiv schnell es führt so
eine natürliche immunität der
gesamtbevölkerung mit in funk und dann
genießen ein starkes und dann waren wir
im herbst auf das problem nicht mehr so
fern können wir jetzt von der
impfpflicht abstand nehmen jeder der
sich impfen lassen will sollte das tun
ich rate auch noch dazu dass auf jeden
fall zu tun aber wir sollten mal mehr
dazu verpflichten abgesehen davon dass
er es auch gar nicht durchsetzen können
der jurist ich fand sehr interessant
auch dass julian dazu gesagt hätten da
kommen ja ein bisschen zu meinen ich
habe immer gedacht jetzt in den
vergangenen zwei jahren schlimmer als
jetzt geht es ja gar nicht mehr so das
habe ich wahnsinnig oft den vergangenen
zwei jahren gedacht dann kam der krieg
es geht eben doch schlimm schlimm
schlimmer damit möchte ich auch sie
liebe zuschauer fangen wir denken sie
gerade über grüne spielt es für sie noch
irgendwie eine große rolle bei all den
herzzerreißenden bildern die wir jeden
teilausführung verschiedene sehen und
genau ich jetzt kommt dann auch heute
die nachricht die masken pflicht der gt
jetzt angesprochen die sie in den
schulen die soll fallen und dann freue
ich mich endlich mal eine gute nachricht
aber moment die betonung liegt hier
wieder auf soll mich auf wird denn wer
neuer sie wird folgt fahren wir in
deutschland weiter eine runde auf dem
panini kubicki ich weiß nächste woche
gesetzt da kommen wir auch gleich zu
aber dennoch über die situation gerade
hamburg macht nicht mit die kinder
dürfen musikunterricht die meist wenn
sie in die gleiche richtung singen und
in bayern müssen die kinder zunächst mal
die maske weiter tragen ausser im
sportunterricht und dann gibt es immer
noch eltern weiterhin auf zero wird
wochen und vor einer durchseuchung übern
und ich sage ihnen ganz ehrlich ich will
auch nicht dass meine kinder corona
bekommen aber ich habe diese woche
gedacht so können wir auch nicht weiter
machen willst wenn es eben doch noch
schlimmer kommt als wir alle dachten
dann hilft nur noch eins menschlichkeit
und aufeinander achtgeben und besonders
auf unsere kinder acht geben und sie
müssen einfach jetzt in jedem bundesland
frei werden von der maske in der schule
ich weiß herr kubicki ich gebe ihnen
gleich das wort das wird kommen nächste
woche aber nach all dem was wir in zwei
jahren erlebt haben in diesem land nie
erlauben sie mir eine gewisse
restzweifel daran ist dass auch in der
nächsten woche und dann auch in allen
bundesländern passiert wird denn es
scheint mir so dass wieder jedes
bundesland sein eigenes süppchen
irgendwo kochen wird und es kleine wege
geben wird wie man doch drum herum kommt
aber sie haben das wort wenn sie mir
versprechen können dann im april ist die
masken freiheit in den schulen darf ich
glaube es ihnen gerne ich versteh ich
verspreche ihnen dass sie in dem neuen
text schutzgesetz es keine regelung zu
finden gibt masken pflicht anzuordnen in
den schulen und das wird spätestens am
zweiten april und am dritten april
überall der fall sein dass die massen
pflichtzeit warum weil die länder noch
zwei wochen lang eine
übergangsvorschriften anspruch nehmen
können damit es keine regelungslücke
gibt führen wird es hat um deren jetzt
die gefahren dürfen bis zum zweiten hat
für den grad bleiben aber spätestens am
zweiten april am dritten april kann ich
versprechen die maske fleet
deutschlandweit an allen schulen in
brüssel und dennoch muss ich ihnen sagen
es soll sich dann ja es wird dir jetzt
schon nach seinem kleinen feinheiten
gesucht um sich auch auf den winter
vorzubereiten und da will man sich ja
nicht mehr anschwellen werten
orientieren bei wir haben jetzt gelernt
neu von karl lauterbach das bringt ihr
überhaupt gar nichts schwellenwerte also
das was uns zwei jahre lang durch die
pandemie getragen hat mit instanzen und
so weiter das ist jetzt quatsch das
bringt gar nichts mehr deswegen möchte
man nur noch auf sogenannte hotspots
schauen und auch schauen ob es
gefährliche varianten gibt oder ob eben
in den krankenhäusern ein problem
auftritt und genau da denke ich wird es
dann eben wieder natürlich nicht zu
flächendeckenden schulschließungen und
flächendeckenden masken pflicht in den
schulen kommen herr fleischer aber
natürlich auch wieder gebietsweise oder
bin ich sehr zu pessimistisch ich weiß
nicht gerne wieder
ja also bei kind geht in bayern zur
schule bislang wieder strenger masken
pflicht jetzt hat unser
ministerpräsident der ja immer auch ein
bisschen mit nase im wind hat schon
vorher angekündigt dass die woche war im
sportunterricht schon freigabe und
nächste woche dann insgesamt in den
schulen also die maske insgesamt euch
sagen dass so
dass wir das überhaupt so hingenommen
haben
ich habe mich neulich bitten damit die
kinder erste unterhalten das hat
natürlich schon gravierende auswirkungen
auch auf entwicklung kleiner kinder weil
also monatelanges reden wir gar nicht
vom atmen ja also mein sohn geht eine
ganztagsschule das heißt er hat für
morgens um acht uhr wo das schulgebäude
betreten hat bis um 15 uhr 20 wo ich ihn
abgeholt habe durchgängig maske getragen
außer beim essen sondern einfach in der
entwicklung eines kindes wenn es
gesichtsmimik nicht wahrnehmen kann das
führt zunächst zu schwierigkeiten beim
lernen
weil zb bei fremdsprachen und andere
mehr ich die die lippenbewegungen nicht
sehen kann aber wie mir diese erst sinn
erklärte gerade bei kindern sagen wir
mal und das ist ja dieses also mein kind
nur so dass in der ersten klasse ist
jetzt genau die zeit zwischen dem
fünften und siebten achten lebensjahr wo
sich so etwas wie ein soziales
verständnis herstellt das muss ich
lernen und das findet ganz viel über
mich und mimik und gestik statt und wenn
ich das gar nicht in der schule einüben
kann dann dass bestimmte kinder die das
wahnsinnig in ihrer entwicklung zurück
wirft also ist es viel mehr als nur
atmend gründler nicht frei atmen können
so und das finde ich das für mich immer
auch deprimierende gewesen der letzten
zwei jahre man sieht eben
leben an wen die regierung damals zuerst
denkt er nicht in die kinder stark wie
zuletzt ja und die kinder standen leider
ganz ganz weit unten ich muss sagen mir
war die maske insofern immer lange zeit
recht weil ich dachte hauptsache sie
machen die schulen nicht mehr zu also
doch lieber die kinder rein bevor wieder
alles noch schlimmer geht's immer
deswegen habe ich auch quasi eben gerade
so angefangen wenn man immer denkt das
geht nicht immer es geht eben doch
schlimmer und bevor man das quasi wieder
macht das ist auch meine große sorge
dass wir irgendwann wieder in die
situation kommen wenn man sagt nein und
das war dann doch alles schwere und die
masken wir abgeschafft also genau das
szenario was sie eben gerade auch mit
der impfpflicht aufgezeichnet haben da
habe ich jetzt sorge mit der masken
pflicht und ich glaube dass wir jetzt zu
einem punkt gekommen sind und damit
spielt auch die situation in der wir
jetzt sind eine große rolle dass man
sagt es wird irgendwie so weitergehen
dieses corona thema wird uns weiter
begleiten vermutlich über jahre lang
konnte ich mir denken aber dann müssen
wir doch an den punkt kommen wo wir
etwas ändern denn wenn wir so
weitermachen ich habe dreijährige
zwillinge verdi einkaufen gehen spielen
dann setzen sie sich eine maske auf weil
die anderen sind nicht ins spielzimmer
einlässt wenn sie einkaufen spielen und
da waren punktrichter irgendwie müssen
wir schauen dass wir uns als menschen
auch wieder finden also der fleischers
anekdotisch haben will ich auch mal ganz
kurz machen mein sohn in die kita seit
letzten sommer und der hat alle
krankheiten gehabt die man sich
vorstellen kann auch jetzt gerade außer
corona und ich fast wir hatten so eine
angst wir haben wir haben die
schulkinder gesehen die maske getragen
haben wie kann unser kind das auch nur
überleben ohne maske und immer wieder
infizieren sich kinder in seiner gruppe
und seiner aktie auch alle und für uns
was schon wieder ein mysterium also das
hat sich nicht verbreitet wie man denkt
wenn einer hat dann hat er mit jemandem
gehört auch das ging immer hin und her
hat meiner gehabt hat mein mann nicht
gehabt wir haben zumindest keinen
eindeutigen zusammenhang gesehen und wir
haben auch viele freunde die kinder
haben und die sechs sieben acht jahre
und so weiter die muster einer maske
aufsetzen sie haben es einen gekriegt
anderen nicht gekriegt ein mann zu
lassen hat sich verbreitet einander
klassen hat sich nicht verbreitet was
ich sagen möchte ist der eindeutige
zusammenhang zwischen kinder mit einer
maske schützen sich eher von corona
gegenseitig von der infektion als kinder
ohne maske den sehe ich bis heute nicht
und den zu unserem glück gehabt wenn wir
auf uns geklappt hat es bisher ist es
bisher nicht so weit gekommen ich frage
mich nur immer wenn man doch bei 45
jährigen kindern das gesehen hat dass es
eben sich nicht ja viral verbreitet wie
so war es dann bei 67 jährigen kindern
überhaupt nicht möglich auch nur zu
überlegen ob man vielleicht gerade
dieser so wichtigen phase auch für die
kinder entwicklungsphase
probeweise vielleicht auch darauf zu
verzichten ich frage mich auch warum es
nicht geschafft haben die schulen
mittlerweile so auszustatten dass man
auch ohne maske relativ sicher
unterricht machen kann indem man ein
bisschen abstand hält ist fenster öffnet
luftfilter will ich gar nicht erst
anfangen aber das wäre alles ein thema
vermutlich für eine gewinnung hierbei
viertel acht wenn wir über den zustand
der schulen reden denn hier in berlin
gibt es ja auch die anbieter kürzungen
aber das wie gesagt ein weiteres thema
für weitere sendungen hier viertel nach
acht ich will mich ganz herzlich
bedanken bei meinen gästen vor uns immer
in kiew der uns jetzt nicht mehr
zugeschaltet ist der weiterhin für sie
aus der ukraine berichtet bayern
fleischhauer für mich ganz herzlich
bedanken bei wolfgang kubicki uns
zugeschaltet herzlichen dank für ihre
zeit und auch bei julia rüttgers hat mir
wahnsinnig viel spaß gemacht ich habe
mich gefreut dass sie uns zugesehen
haben wenn man sich gut
danke ihnen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bild